うん
ん
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
45年間生きてきた中で人生の選択を何度か繰り返して今の自分がここにいます
人生の選択に迷ったときみなさんはどうやって進む道を決めていますか
例えば先が見えている安定した道と
先は見えないけどなんだかワクワクする道
私は1度きりの人生楽しまなきゃもったいないって思っているのでリスクがあったとし
てもいつもワクワクする道を選んでいます
生きろ味わうために
45年前
のどかな田園地帯が広がる田舎町で
鉢を育て蜂蜜を取る予報以下の娘として生まれてきました
私にとって蜂蜜は生活の一部にごく当たり前にそこにある存在でした
幼い頃絵を書くことと押されが好きだった私はファッションデザイナーを夢見て
子ども時代を過ごしました
進路を決める時田舎の両親はデザイナーになるのは簡単ではないと他の道を進めました
が
夢をあきらめることがどうしてもできなかった私は
生活費は自分で何とかするからと自分の未来を信じて
デザインの道に進みました
高校生のときにバイトで貯めた100万円を握りしめてワクワクしながら小喬しました
が
借りられたのは風呂なしのオンボロアパートでした
学校に通いながら
深夜3時まで働くというハードな生活でしたが
それでも夢に向かっている私はとても幸せでした
3年後ずっと憧れていたデザイナーの夢を叶えることができました
ところが絶頂期の7年目
私に突然人生の転機が訪れたのです
料理人だった夫にスイスで働かない母という話が来たのです
スイスといえばあの子供の頃にずっと見ていたハイジの世界です
私はもうなんだかワクワクして迷わずスイス行きを決めました
あんなに苦労して鍋たデザイナーの道をあっさり辞めてまで
新しい世界に沸く博している自分がそこにいたからです
とはいえ
もともと英語が苦手だった上にスイスはドイツ語です
1年間語学スクールに通ったとはいえ
まるで幼稚園児です
おまけにお腹も大きくなってきて働くこともできません
このまま異国の地で何もしないまま人生はあるのかと思ったとき
今ある現状で私らしく生きたいと強く願いました
言葉の壁という枠は外して私がここでやれることをやりたいことを探しました
専門学校時代に学んだ洋裁技術を生かしてお直し屋さんを始めたのです
あのリームをしながら頑張って学んだことが私の財産となっていたのです
成功も失敗も
そして遠回りの人生も
その時の経験すべては自分の財産になるものだと強く感じました
椅子で長男を出産し日本に里帰りした時に
養蜂家の父がそろそろ引退すると私たちに告げました
跡継ぎがいないと知った夫はなんと両方継ぐ決意をしたのです
8を見れば逃げ回るような夫だったので正直私は心配でした
でもそんな音が後を継いでくれよぉとしているし
両親も喜んでいる
どうせあるんだったら私も楽しく仕事がしたいと思いました
ですが現実は甘くありません
100年続く養蜂場だったので市内の人は皆家のことをしてくれていると思い込んでい
たのですが
現実はそうでないことに愕然としました
このままでは家族を守れない
そう思った私は蜂蜜の他に何かできることはないか探しました
たまたまファッションが好きだった私はリスクもなく
し金もいらない痛く式のリサイクルショップを始めたのです
ある時フリーマーケットでチラシを配っているときに一人の新聞記者の方と出会いいい
彼女が書いてくれた記事のおかげでお客様はどんどん増えていきました
すると今度は新しいお客様ははちみつをどう使っていいかわからないというので
ハチミツを使ったカフェをやってみようと思いました
ところが
当時はやれなさそうな条件ばかりが揃っていました
カフェの経験ノウハウがない
改装資金にお金がかかる
幼い二人の子育て真っ最中
お店の周りには何にもない
場所が本当にわかりにくい
もうこれだけやれなさそうな条件が揃っていたら普通なら諦めるのでしょうがやりたい
と思ったら
報道しないと気が済まない私は主人と2人でお店の改装を始めたり
カフェのメニューを考えたりやれることから始めました
そして半年後はちみつカフェとしてオープンすることができたのです
口コミで広がりテレビの取材も来て順調に進んでいるときに
今度はどうしても3人目の子供が欲しくなったのです
新生児を抱えながらさすがにお店に立つのは難しいと思ったので
カフェを続けるか子供を産むか
私の目の前にまた洗濯の道が現れました
どちらも諦めきれなかった私は思い切って
カフェの運営をスタッフに任せることにしたのです
やれない理由で夢をあきらめずにやれる方法を探せばいいのです
やらないで後悔するくらいならやってしまえばいいのです
もし失敗したとしてもまた違う方法でトライすればいいし
辛く苦しい思いをしたらその道は自分に合っていなかったんだって方向転換すればいい
んです
それは逃げるんではなく
なりたい自分に出会うための選択なのです
2年前私の目の前に
また選択すべき道が現れました
世の中のミツバチが消えかかっている
多く原因の多くは農薬や病気
そして
蜜源の減少です
このまま蜂蜜蜂はハチミツを取るだけでなく
花粉交配の役目をし私たち人間の食糧問題に大きく関わる大切な生き物です
そのミツバチが消えていくのをじっと待つのかそれとも養蜂家として何かアクションが
起こせるのか
その答えが見つかったとき私はじっとしていられませんでした
空いている土地をレンゲでいっぱいにして
蜂蜜はもちろんのこと
電源マイヤー米粉など自分たちが誇れる特産品をみんなでつくる
電源いっぱいプロジェクトを発足したのです
レンゲの蜜はミツバチの食料となり電源おすきこむことで田畑の肥料になります
私たちの町にはこれといった観光資源や特産品がなかったのでこのレンゲが私たちの街
を活性できるんじゃないかと考えるともうワクワクしてきました
このプロジェクト多くの方に知って頂こうとチラシやポスターを作り
市長に手紙も書きました
最初は
1人で活動を始めたため公民館にをスターを張るのでさえ困難でしたが
これは一人でやる活動ではなくみんなでつくるプロジェクトなんだと話していくうちに
一人二人と協力者が増えていき
今では電源のはが少しずつ広がっています
あの時
私なんかがと諦めずに
私ならできると自分を信じ
私がやると心を決めたから今があります
私が小境に戻った時に夢がいたのは
住んでいる人たちが誇れる故郷であり
訪れた人がワクワクするような
心躍るような魅力的な街です
何もないなら作ればいいし思い立ったらやってみる
夢を叶えるためにいろんなことに挑戦してきました
最初はたった1人から
一人はとても勇気がいりますが
勇気を出して一歩前に踏み出せば自分の道は決めていけるし
未来は変えられるのです
げんげいっぱいになった故郷にたくさんの人が訪れるように
そして
愛するミツバチのために
今日も私はワクワクの花
ワクワクの種をまき続けます
ありがとうございます